je quitte jamais le mais le jeu
julie et thomas vous invitent à leur
mariage mais c'est à vous de gagner les
informations lieu de la cérémonie ou
horaires du cocktail des surprises à
débloquer dans un jeu vidéo en tant que
personne qui a uni tant que hôte
j'envoie à mes invités se faire part via
email via facebook via sms
c'est un jeu en ligne qui est
personnalisé à mon image 85% des jeunes
jouer aux jeux vidéo et 66 % et + 35 ans
à plus forte progression ces les seniors
dans tout le monde peut utiliser le jeu
vidéo attrape moi si tu peux et le
premier jeu d'une longue série
une aventure rendu possible grâce à une
opération de crowdfunding elle leur a
permis de récolter plus de 6000 euros
anniversaire crémaillère naissance ou
départ à la retraite je dis oui
proposera différentes versions en
fonction des événements on trouvera une
multitude de jeux on pourra choisir son
jeu et en fonction de la mutation est en
fonction de qui on veut l'envoyer soit
pour entreprise ou particulier au niveau
du design en fait aujourd'hui répartis
en effet sur un peu un peu vintage mais
on a un champ qui est ouvert sur d
autres langues à l'avenir prix de ce
carton d'invitation deux points 0,59
euro
le premier je termine sa phase de test
il faudra encore patienter jusqu'à cet
automne
morgenthau
[Musique]